grumpy language Grandpa here again today
grumpy today because I had a comment on
my YouTube channel from a teacher in
Spain responding to my video don't learn
the basics he or she says without a
doubt we need to focus on the basics
because what people are missing in Spain
his students are precisely numbers
alphabet the times ordinal numbers
Etc which are necessary Etc yeah and
what do you think people are taught in
all language courses in all language
books from the beginning numbers times
of the day the alphabet and all those
things and actually they're difficult to
learn the basics are hard to learn we
continue to struggle with the basics so
just let the language come at you and
trust your brain the brain will figure
things out according to the normal
natural order of acquisition